okay guys welcome back to Gary's
economics this week we got something a
little bit different for you we are
going to show you um a live record
Another speech I gave at Cambridge to
kick off my book launch a couple of
months ago um I got to be honest if
we've gotten around to this point it
means basically we have run out of
videos and the reason for that is
because I am currently on holiday
cycling from Tokyo to kagoshima in
Southwestern Japan um listen it's been a
pretty mental year for me I've been
working really hard Channel's growing a
lot uh I've had a ton of publicity with
the book um trying to grow everything
trying to push things politically and
it's been a lot of work and uh to be
honest I'm feeling a little bit
creatively exhausted and um you know we
get a lot of support for this channel
now I've got a manager and we've got
Jack here the videographer but but
creatively it's still basically me who
does the videos and um with all the book
and the interviews and the the video for
the channel I'm feeling a bit knackered
and and the election all that nonsense
um so I've decided to get out of here go
back to Japan um those of you who read
the book when I lived in Japan for two
years and I used to spend a lot of time
in there before covid so I've decided to
take a little bit of a break go and do
this cycle that I've wanted to do for
ages from Tokyo to to Southwest Japan
and um I've tried my best to film videos
to fill the Gap but I'm not sure we're
going to be able to cover the whole time
and uh We've scheduled this to be the
last video before uh before we go blank
for a bit maybe for part of August
before I come back for my holiday and
this is a speech I gave at Robinson
college in Cambridge um it's a little
bit more personal a little bit more
emotional than a lot of the stuff that I
do talking about sort of how I deal with
sort of living in this economy which
where things get worse and worse and
trying to stop it um I think it's a
really nice speech and I promised uh a
room full of scousers in waterstones
Liverpool that I'd put it up on the you
at some point so hopefully they're still
watching um unfortunately there's a few
problems with the sound quality um but
since we've got a gap with no videos I
think it's worth watching I think it's
really interesting it's about 45 minutes
long I hope you like it uh I get a
little bit emotional in it but um after
this I think we'll probably have a gap
of a few weeks before I come back in
September and start shooting again so
this will be it for me for a few weeks
um I'll back and I hope you enjoy this
last video thank you and also thanks for
all of your help um this year the growth
been been really good and been really
mental and and hopefully be able to have
a little bit more political impact when
I come back thank
you when I was contacted to do this
lecture they said come to Robinson
college talk about economics tell
everyone why inequality is a
problem and my agent said that's perfect
timing for your book launch to go do it
so I said yes and um that's about a year
ago now I didn't really think about it
much then they reached out to me a
couple of months ago and they said what
you want the
title your lecture to
be and
um my first thought when they said that
was I don't really want to talk about
economics anymore
let me explain to you why I've been
talking about economics for a long time
now 13 years 14 years I've been having
arguments about economics trying to tell
people inequality is a problem
inequality is a problem it's going to
get worse it's going to get worse we
need to do
something and over the course of those
14 years especially in the last year or
two what I've noticed
is the arguments been having have been
changing and more and more I start to
think to myself that actually we're not
really arguing about economics at
all see when I first started saying
inequality was a problem I was working
in a bank in Canary wolf in London and I
was surrounded by millionaires of
Economics degrees and they would say to
me you can't tax wealth you can't deal
with inequality because we need the rich
to invest to grow the economy me the
optimal rate of Taxation in the first
best of all possible worlds on capital
is
zero but nobody really says that to me
anymore okay some people do say that
sometimes in places like this people say
that
but nobody without a fancy economics
degree says that to me no
more what people say to me now
is you can't tax the rich you can't tax
they're too powerful he attacks the rich
they'll leave and they'll go away and
then we'll have nothing and then we'll
be
poor or they say to
me it's impossible trying to deal with
inequality inequality is just the way
things are and the rich are too powerful
why you trying to stop them you're
wasting your
time what they say to me why are you
trying to stop
inequality why don't you just trade
Bitcoin or foreign exchange on internet
that's the way to make everything
better or they say to
me you know the economy and Society it's
like the cycles of
nature sometimes it's good and sometimes
it's bad sometimes it gets better and
sometimes it gets worse so why are you
trying to change
things you can't fight the cycles of
Nature and the more more I heard these
arguments the more I started to think
we're not really
arguing about the
economy increasingly everybody knows
it's getting worse and
worse really hardly any real people
think it's going to get
better I think people in their heart of
hearts
realize that it just gets worse and
worse from here and when they're saying
to
me why are you trying to fix things
often they're really saying to
themselves I don't want to have to try
to fix
things and I started to feel like the
real questions that we're asking
ourselves and each other it's not really
is the economy
broken it's what do you
do what do you do when you live in a
collapsing
economy what do you do what should you
do
and what does it
mean more and more these are the
questions that I hear when I argue
people about
economics what do you do what should you
do what does it
mean and it got me thinking about my
journey in
economics I've been an economist
for God nearly 20 years now but I lived
in an economy my whole
life I grew up very poor so really
poverty and a collapse in economy is not
new
to but I got me
thinking what did I
do what should I have done
differently what does it all
mean so I sent a ma back saying I wanted
to talk about what it means to be human
in a collapsing economy and I'm going to
talk a little bit
about what I think about my
path and
when I talk about that I want you to
think about those three main
questions what does it mean to live in a
collapsing
economy what do you do when the economy
is
collapsing and what should you do and
I'm going to stop a points and I'm going
to ask those questions and when I do
that I would like you to think what
would I do if that was
me and with regards to the second of
those questions what do you do when the
economy is collapsing all of you will
have a perspective on that because you
all live in aoll economy and you're all
doing
something but this kind of economic
collapse which is in my opinion a
collapse caused by inequality it's a
collapse which looks very very different
depending on which angle you view it
from so some of you will have been in
the situations I've been there and some
of you won't have
been but I want you to take it as an
opportunity to imagine you're in a
different seat to where you are now and
ask yourself honestly what would I do if
that was
me okay so with that I'm going to start
I don't like reading from speeches but
I've written a little
story when I was writing I wanted to
start with my period of BTY which lasted
about 20 years and um I wrote a little
bit about ilford which is my hometown so
I'm going to read it to
you I'm going to have to change this
first line because there's a swear word
in
it I grew up in
ilford it's a bit of a
slump but it's my slump
ORD is kind of a contested Borderland
war zone between East London and
Essex everyone is from Pakistan or India
or Sri Lanka or something but everyone
talks in a half cottony
accent when I was a teenager I used to
sing songs in Punjabi for illegal
immigrants working in halal Fried
Chicken shops at 2 a.m. in the morning
for free
chicken what do you want me to tell you
I loved it
I still do I miss
it ilford is one of the cheapest places
to live in all of
London I used to live in this tiny
narrow Terrace House on A Street full of
tiny narrow Terrace houses tucked him
behind the High Street it had three
bedrooms it used to have two bedrooms
but somebody had moved the bathroom
downstairs into the kitchen which meant
that they could turn the old bathroom
upstairs into another bedroom
and that's where I grew up in a bunk bed
with my brother in a bunk bed in an old
converted
bathroom the train trucks that carried
Brokers and Traders in fast trains from
out in Essex down into the city used to
run right through my garden right past
my bedroom window and when the fast
trains came through the whole house used
to
shake I never
noticed when when you grow up in a house
that gets shaken by a fast train every 4
minutes you don't even notice when a
train shakes your
house I was 12 or 13 the first time I
noticed my friend from school came
around and he
said damn your whole house is
shaking and that was the first time I
realized what does that
mean so I was in the bottom bunk of that
bunk bed when I was a kid and underne my
bed there was a single drawer that had
been removed from a chest of drawers
which had probably been destroyed long
ago and in that single draw I kept all
of my worldly
possessions I'll be honest it wasn't
particularly safe house when I was a
kid there was danger and there was
violence
sometimes but you know I was a kid what
do you
do and there are a lot of institutions
in our society that are supposed to
protect poor kids and kids who are not
safe there's the government the welfare
state charity philanthropy some
religious
institutions all I can tell you is I
don't remember none of them coming from
me so you know what do you
do there wasn't any help as far as I can
remember it when I was a kid but there
was a
story a story is something to hold on to
you work hard you kill all of your exams
you destroy the
competition your friends of
course you beat all your friends into
the top
university this
University and then you get a whole load
of new friends and you beat those new
friends too into the best job and then
you get the best job working for a bank
in the
city I did didn't really know what that
meant to be honest but I had an
image it was an image of a large corner
office high up in a skyscraper somewhere
with carpeted floors and windows for
walls and a high blue sky and a warm sun
and Views some miles in every
direction I don't actually know if
offices like that really
exist I never worked in
one but you know that was a story
I got to be honest I didn't really work
hard there wasn't anywhere to work in my
house the only desk in the whole house
was this little kind of Bureau thing
that you had to fold out right next to
my dad's bed and when you did a whole
load of M flew at you it was so dark and
musty there that I don't think anyone
could work
there but my parents had a solution they
got this like plank of wood and if you
sat on the armchair you could put the
planker with the cross and you could
balance your books and you could write
there
but I didn't really like doing that
because the plank wasn't that long and
it would fall and your books would fall
on the
floor so I just went down to the floor
with them and I put the plank down on
the floor and I used to work there lying
down on my belly in the middle of the
front room doing my Math's homework and
my French homework as my dad used to
watch Coronation Street and my brother
and sister used to run around screaming
and causing
Carnage what do you do you know I didn't
work
hard instead I was out on the
streets you know my street was like a
little dead end Street tucked in between
the High Street and the railway and on
one end where there was this old
abandoned Factory we used to play in and
on the other end there was this
recycling center which had these huge 3
meter high piles of old newspapers we
used to play on them as
well but there was never any traffic on
that street and the kids used to just
play out every
day and when the first Canary War
skyscrapers went up which was happening
when I was about 9 or 10 we could see
those skyscrapers go up in a
distance and so I thought that's it then
that's where I'm going to
be looks like a lot of corner offices in
that
building maybe some other kids thought
the
same but you know I wasn't really
studying but you might think that's a
problem but to be honest
it
weren't cuz even though I Wen never
studying I still came first in every
exam and I don't know
why I don't know what that
means and the kids at school would say
oh we you know you're studying and I
would say I'm not I'm not
studying and they would say we know that
you are and I don't know what you say to
that so I used to take him sometimes
back to see my house the house used to
shape with the trains and then they knew
that I wasn't studying
because I
wasn't not long after that I got
expelled from school see I managed to
get into some fancy grammar school and
the kids there knew that I could get
drugs and they were right I could get
drugs there were drugs on my street
there was about 10 houses I could have
knocked on at any time and those front
doors would open up and they'd sell me
drugs and those kids at the grammar
school from fancy homes and fancy houses
and staircases that split in two in the
middle
they didn't have doors that opened up
like that on their
streets but what they did have was
money
money so they brought their money that I
didn't have and I brought my drugs which
they didn't have and we met then in
bounous free Commerce and it wasn't them
it was me that got expelled wasn't it
and I didn't know quite what that
meant what would you do
you know when I was very young primary
school I had the school trip to the
seaside at that time I owned two pairs
of
shoes one was a pair of black school
shoes that were a hand me down for my
older
brother I wore those to school and to
church I also had one pair of black
plims also a hand me- down for my
brother
I War those for everything
else that day on the
seaside I took off my PLM sols and I ran
into the sea and I played in the
waves and when I came back to the shore
the pl Souls were gone I guess the waves
must have taken
them after that I wore the black school
shoes for
everything PE class everything I wore
them until they fell apart
part I don't know you know what would
you
do and now this brings us to our first
moral
question at this
point we see in sharp moral
Focus the meaning of what it is to be
poor and to try to be
rich so imagine
this you are there for the first day of
your new
life you're 16 you've just been expelled
from
school in the night time you were awoken
by your mother crying at the foot of
your
bed but she's gone now everyone's gone
now your mom and your dad and your
brother are at work your younger sister
she's still in
school there's no one in the house and
there's no school to go
to so you get out of bed and you go
downstairs to the bathroom which is in
the kitchen and you plug a little
plastic hose into the TOs of the bathtub
and you sit down on the cold plastic and
you shower yourself and you watch the
water go down the drain and you say to
yourself that's your life that is that's
your
life and then you get out of the bath
and you dry yourself and you're drying
your hair on the doorbell rings and it's
your friend from the street who you've
been smoking with for about 6 months now
and he knows that you've been expelled
from school and he's really sorry and he
says we should go and smoke
up so
now what do you
do this is the moment when you realize
that to be poor and to want to be rich
is a walking
away it is a walking away from the
friends you grew up with it is a walking
away from people like
you and you know deep within yourself in
your heart of hearts these friends won't
be okay without you
but what about you if you stick around
to save him then who sticks around to
save
you what does it mean to be
selfish what would you do if it were
you what would you
do I didn't
go I
worked I worked there by myself in that
cold empty house B down in the center of
the front room math
homework chemistry homework English
homework every day on that small wooden
board and I did it I killed my
exams I decimated the
opposition I outco competed my
friends I won then my first taste of
blood so what next
3 years later the London School of
Economics
money so I'll be honest I thought LC was
going to be difficult but to be honest
it wasn't that
hard millionaires kids Gaddafi's kids
paying tens of thousands of pounds to
send their kids over to London from all
over the world to get beat by me in
their
exams I don't know why to be
honest I don't really know what that
means
but I had a desk
then not a home there was a desk in
library so now you're at LC you're 19
years old you're studying maths and
economics which is basically the same as
economics because economics is mostly
math
nowadays your focus now is on smashing
the other students killing them in their
exams making it clear to everyone that
you are the best student in the union
and beating everyone to the the top job
that will make you a
millionaire everyone else is trying to
do the same
thing nobody's really that bothered in
trying to work out how the economy works
why would we be we didn't go there to do
that you know we were there to kill to
compete to make money it's not about
knowledge was that the right thing to
do should you spend your time actually
trying to understand the
economy and let everyone else beat you
in your
exams then you'll never be able to get a
job to actually do anything with that
knowledge what would you
do I made my decision pretty quickly and
I killed everyone in the first two
exams I thought that was the right path
to getting me a millionaire job but it
turns out it
wasn't because whilst grades are
important to getting the top jobs
nowadays other things are more
important the actual way you get a good
job nowadays is sending a CV and cover
letter so what do you put on your CV and
cover letter when you 19 years old
you've been expelled from school for
selling drugs you did a pay round for
six years you spent three years fluffing
pillows in a sofa shop in beckon next to
a sewage work you spent a year and a
half trying to become a Grime
MC my friend was the junior United
Nations my other friend played OB at the
Royal
Al he founded the charity that runs dirt
bike tours through the Sahara Desert for
some
reason why were their CVS so much better
than
mine they were better because they knew
more likely their parents had known they
had known that the day would come when
the children of this world would be
divided based on who and who could not
play the
oow so they made sure that their kids
had
oows and that's how jobs are allocated
in this world it's not about exams I see
that
now what does that
mean what do you
do okay so you need to find a new route
you need to sneak in through the back
door despite the fact that your grades
are the best in the whole
university you look for a back door and
you find one competition card game One
Bank runs a card game across five
universities in the country the winner
of the whole competition gets an
internship
game sounds
nice sounds fair doesn't
it sounds like you don't need to play
the oow at
least but it's risky isn't it it's a
game so what you do you do some research
and you manage to find out the rules of
the game before the competition itself
then when you walk into the competition
against the other wealthy economic
students you win at least partially
because you had an
advantage an unfair Advantage you
cheated in a sense you cheated to
win what does that mean you cheated to
win a game that you needed to win in
order to get a job despite being one of
the top students in the whole
university what does that mean is that
fair is that
human what would you
do okay so now you get the job now
you're a Trader the best job in the
world there's no Corner offices it's a
big
room it's the job everybody
wanted you get to the trading floor of
one of the world's biggest banks and
it's full of Genius millionaires
except it's it's not really is it it's
full of men with nice shirts expensive
haircuts it's kind of full of obvious
Psychopaths with emotional problems and
people who shout a lot and aren't really
that smart and you suppose that that
should have been obvious really because
it's full of the same people you studied
with at LC and they were never really
chosen because they were smart they were
chosen because their dads were
Rich what does that mean
so you're there now you're young and
you're hungry and you're there to make
money and you want to learn from someone
you want to learn how to trade how to
make money but everyone there's kind of
insane and then suddenly it's October
2008 and the world blows up and Leman
goes bankrupt and seven of your friends
who studied with you at the London
School of economics and had only just
started working there lose their jobs
and TV cameras go down to their office
which is just down the road from your
office and your friends pack all their
personal possessions into little green
Leman Brothers duffel bags that they'
received just a couple weeks earlier as
a welcome gift for managing to get one
of the best jobs in the entire world and
they carry those little green duffel
bags and cardboard boxes full of their
possessions down into taxis down to the
station and TV cameras film them and you
see them on TV
and you feel bad for them because you
know them because you study with
them but you don't feel bad for them
really because you know they should have
chosen better when they got randomly
assigned a bank just like
you what does that
mean what would you
do and everyone around you starts to
make money two traders in my team of
traders made $100 million in profit the
year Li went
under so what do you do
I know what I did I started to copy them
even though I had no idea what any of
them were doing and the next
year I made $12 million in
profit but that year there was a lot of
public discontent about the pay and the
bankers bonuses the bankers who in their
eyes had ruined the global
economy and I sat there on the trading
floor and I was still a poor boy
sleeping on broken mattresses still
showering with a hose in my parents
bathtub only now surrounded by
millionaires as golden brown the then
prime minister of my country said he
would tax the bankers he would tax their
bonuses and I looked around and the
millionaires around me were laughing and
one of them grabbed my shoulder and he
said don't worry Gary don't never tax
us and I took a big breath in and I
breathed it all out
what does that
mean what would you
do I waited for my first big
bonus I was expecting it to be
100,000 at that time in my life 00,000
was the biggest sum of money that I
could
imagine my dad had worked his whole life
for 20,000 a
year what I got was 395,000
P what does that
mean what would you
do you know when I was in sixth form I
would skip lunch to save
money my friend Assad would sometimes
feel bad for me and he'd buy me a burger
meal from a shop called Pizza King
around the corner from the school and
I'd have it with burger sauce know that
orange
sauce when I was at Uni for lunch I
would buy two Scotch eggs from Tesco for
75p every day for 2
years and then one day when I just
turned 23 someone gave me 395,000
what does that
mean what would you
do I wanted
more the next year
2010 I copied everyone again and it
didn't work for the first time ever I
lost money I lost $8 million in one
single week when the Swiss National Bank
unexpectedly cut its interest rates to
4.5% that was the first time ever that
it occurred to me that maybe LSC had
done me a
disservice maybe memorizing answers and
not actually learning anything wasn't
really that useful maybe you did need to
know about the economy after
all who
knew but that moment began an obsession
for me
an obsession that continues to dat an
obsession to understand the
economy why did I want to understand the
economy because I wanted to make
money what does that
mean what would you
do so around about that time late 2010
early
2011 I was starting to understand that
nobody had any idea what they were
doing see my job was to predict interest
rates to summarize quite aggressively
interest rates go down when the economy
is weak and up when the economy is
strong by the beginning of
2011 I had witnessed markets predict
interest rates completely incorrectly
for three
years see cutting interest rates to zero
is supposed to stimulate the economy
that's what we are taught at
University due to the massive interest
rate Cuts in 2008 economists all
expected the economy to bounce back
sharply in
2009 it
didn't after that economists expected
the same thing to happen in
2010 it didn't I didn't know at the time
but this pattern would actually continue
for 13
years economists in the UK predicted
economic and interest rate recovery
every single year from 2009 to
2020 in 2020 they finally agreed that
interest rates would actually never go
up
again what does that
mean anyway look I didn't know this at
that time what I knew then was that the
Traders and the economists had been
wrong for three years they were
predicting economic recoveries that
won't
happen
why in my
opinion the reason those Traders and
economists thought the economy would get
better
every single year from 2008 up till now
is because for them we did get
better for the rich life got better and
better and better pretty much every
single year from 2008 up till
now so why did interest rate stay at
zero that Whole Decade after 2010
I had an
idea the reason interest rates are
supposed to stimulate the economy is
because they're supposed to get you
spending but people weren't
spending and I asked a few of the
Traders why and they said you know
there's problems with the banking sector
which are fixed now there's problems
with confidence that are fixed
now one time I asked an Oxford economics
professor why did you think
spending was so weak after
2008 he said there was an exogenous
shock to consumption savings
[Music]
preferences so I decided to do something
radical in the world of
Economics I went out and I started
asking
people have you had an exogenous shock
to your consumption savings
preferences I'm going to read you a
passage from my book because my
publicist be
delighted this is what people
said when I asked them why they weren't
spending more
money I asked Harry
Sami Harry was still just a
kid Harry had holes in his shoes and he
was jumping over the barriers on the
tube to save
costs that's why he didn't spend
money I asked Assad Assad said his mom
had sold the family home to support him
and his sisters and now he was sleeping
on the sofa to try and save up a
deposit that's why they didn't spend
money I asked Aiden Aidan's mom had lost
her job and hadn't been able to get a
new rate on the mortgage now the monthly
payments were Sky High and Aidan was
having to pay them
himself that's why they didn't spend
money they were losing their homes
I hadn't even
noticed so you realize that the hundreds
of billions of pounds they imported into
the economy by governments and central
banks aren't doing anything to protect
Ordinary
People very shortly after that you
recognize that basically every
government in the world is
bankrupt Spain
Italy Portugal Greece but also the UK
the US
Japan at that time early
2011 all of these governments had
massive deficits that were growing they
were selling off their assets they were
going into debt they were losing their
homes but if the government is losing
its assets and going into debt and the
people are losing their assets and going
into debt then where are the assets
going and who's on the other side of the
debt then I look to the right of me and
I look to the left of me and I realized
I was surrounded by
millionaires it was us wasn't it we were
the
balance we were the boys who would be
richer than our fathers in a world full
of kids who'd be
poor it was us we were the ones on the
other side of the Italian government de
we were the ones on the other side of
mom's mortgage we would buy Assad's
mom's house and rent it back to Assad's
kids and then we would have the house
and the debt too would lend it back to
them and it would grow and it would grow
and it would compound and it would
compound the situation wouldn't get
better it would get
worse it wasn't confidence it was
cancer it was never going to get
better what does that mean
I knew what it meant it meant I had to
buy a green euro dollar
Futures that's a bet on interest rates
at that time everybody thought interest
rates would go up but they wouldn't I
put that bet on a massive size and by
the end of the year I was City bank's
most profitable Trader in the
world and City Bank paid me $2 million
and said Well Done mate do it
again what does that mean
what would you
do I did it one more year I am not going
to lie to
you the next year I was sitting at my
desk and I said to one of the young
traders who I worked
with do you think we should do
something he said to me what do you
mean I said you think we should do
something about the collapsing economy
he said' what do you mean I said do you
think we should do
something he said we brought we bought
the green Euro dollars what do you
want I've said people I don't think this
is about the green Euro dollars you know
do you think we should do something
about the collapsing
economy he said to me sorry I don't
understand what do you
mean I tried to explain to him that
maybe we as wealthy people with an
understanding of the problematic economy
should do something to make it
about he said to me Gary that's
impossible and I knew of course that he
was
right but for some reason I quit my job
anyway and I would love to tell you it's
because I'm a good person because I'm a
nice guy but the truth is is because I
was sick I wanted to sit there and make
more money but I was losing weight every
single day I'd bought a new luxury
apartment and I'd ripped all of the
Furnishings out for some reason I
couldn't buy more
and I used to sleep on a mattress on a
bare concrete floor with white plaster
walls and every day I trade a trillion
dollars and be City bank's most
profitable Trader in the
world what does that
mean I'll quit that job and if you want
to hear the story of that it's in the
book but I want to talk about what
happened
afterwards because first I tried
to work for a think
tank and I made a website
called wealth economics it's still up
you can look it if you want explaining
that if you don't fix wealth inequality
the economy will collapse this Theory
made me millions of dollars nobody
looked at the
website you can still look it if you
want but of course nobody's going to
look at the website nobody knows who you
are so what do you do so you go back to
University you go back to University you
go to Oxford best university in the
world contentious
and you go to your first lecture on
interest rates and at this point you've
just stopped being the world's most
profitable interest rates Trader and you
go to the lecture and you say
hey can we talk about why we've been so
wrong about interest rates for the past
10 years and he says to you oh we always
knew interest rates would stay
zero what does that
mean and you say to him no you didn't
you predicted it wrong for 10 years in a
row and he says no we knew we knew and
you say to him okay well I'll go home
and I'll send you the data
and he says oh yeah you're right you
were wrong for 10 years and it don't go
no
further what does that
mean and you go to your midyear review
and you sit there with your college
professors and they ask you what you
think of a
course you told them it's not very good
maybe use some stronger words I've been
asked not to swear in
lecture um and they say why don't you
like it and I say why don't you talk
about people's economic problems and
they turn around to you and they say
what do you mean the economy is good and
you sit there with these three men in
CES in this wood panel Hall and you hear
these two unspoken words reverberate
back from the
walls it's good for
us what does that
mean so you decide you had to leave
University and you have to try and do
something more
active you have to go out and you have
to speak to people directly you have to
tell them if things don't get
better if there's no action on
inequality that their lives are going to
get worse and
worse then immediately there's a
pandemic and the government gives out
800 billion
pounds and you can see from the analysis
right at the beginning that that money
will be accumulated by the rich and
nobody at the
universities in the opposition party in
the government in the Civil Service in
the central banks even ask the question
of who's going to accuse this $800
billion so you put a massive bet on
increasing asset prices and you make
3,000 what does that
mean but you also make a YouTube channel
when you try and tell people this is
going to happen you write in the
guardian that there's going to be a
massive crisis of inequality falling
living standards at the same time Larry
Elliot Chief economics correspondent of
the Guardian predicts that house prices
will
collapse 3 years later you were right
and larel was wrong obviously nobody
remembers what does that
mean and you work and you work and
eventually you manag to build up a
following you put up videos every week
people turn around to you and
say there's no point there's nothing you
can do there's no way to stop it so what
do you
do I want to speak to you about an event
I spoke
at it was at Sai I probably can't
mention it was that fancy uh advertising
company you can edit that out
right and I sat on the stage and I told
him in a much shorter version what I
just told you that the economy will
collapse and it will get worse and worse
I'm not just saying I'm betting on it I
make hundreds of thousands pounds on it
every year I made millions of pounds on
it in my life and the woman next to
you who account seems like a very nice
woman says what gives me hope is that
the economy is like
nature sometimes it gets better and
sometimes it gets
worse and what I heard when she said
that
was my life's
comfortable I ain't going to do
nothing and you start thinking it's
impossible isn't it because the poor are
struggling to put food on the table you
expect them to stand up and defend
themselves
and the rich have got kitchen
renovations to worry about so they're
too busy to
help the problem is people are
inherently selfish
right maybe there's no way out maybe
this is just inevitable it's the way
they work in
society and then I got
sent to do a story in
colan which is in noran Yorkshire
it was about how Rishi sunak is the
richest MP ever and I was going to go to
a food bank and I was going to ask them
how do you feel about having the richest
ever MP in
history and just coincidentally it
happened that Russia invaded Ukraine the
previous weekend before I went up there
and the food bank that I was visiting
had been converted into a place to sort
the donations that were going to be sent
to Ukraine and it was full of people
sorting clothes and medicine and food
into different bin bags and there were
three guys there with vans that were
going to drive the stuff all the way
there to
Ukraine and I started asking the people
you know
like who are these people doing this and
you find out it's the users of the food
bank maybe people are inherently selfish
after
all there's a story in the Bible it's
called the widows might
and it talks about all the people who
give money
extravagantly to charity to
religion and it talks about one Widow
who just put two small couple CS in the
box and apparently I never met him Jesus
said she's given more than everybody
else for all these have of their
abundance cast in unto the offerings of
God but she of her penury have casting
all the living that she
had maybe people are inherently
selfish I don't
know what do you
do I wanted to read a little bit from a
book that I like spinal for called
C this book is called the play and he
talks about what people do in society
that's collapsing apparently it's about
the Nazis but I didn't know because it's
a metaphor or something
and what he says is that basically when
Society collapses most people go
crazy but some people don't and there's
a group of people that that started
trying to fight the
plague Camu
says T started work the very next day
and must the first team that was to be
followed by many
others however it is not the narrator's
intention to attribute more significance
to these Health groups than they
actually had it is true that nowadays
many of our fellow citizens would in his
place succumb to the temptation to
exaggerate their
role but the narrator is rather inclined
to believe that by giving too much
importance to fine actions one may end
by paying an indirect but powerful
tribute to evil because in so doing one
implies that such fine actions are only
valuable because they are rare and that
malice or indifference are far more
common motives in the actions of men
the narrator does not share this
Fe the evil in the world comes almost
always from ignorance and Good Will can
cause as much damage as ill will if it
is not
enlightened C
thinks that when you are in a society
that is
collapsing your job is to stop it from
collapsing kamu thinks that's how you be
human but there a lot of people in this
town that don't agree and he speaks
about this as
well in C's words a lot of new moralists
appeared in the town at this moment
saying that nothing was any use and that
we should go down on our
knees taru Ryu and their friends could
answer this or that but the conclusion
was always what they knew it would be
one must fight in one way or another and
not go down on one's
knees I found that very movie when I
read
that now in K's story most people when
Society collapses go crazy they become
extremely religious or they become
extremely hedonistic or they become
extremely greedy and they try to make
money they become really angry and try
to find people to
hate and I think this is natural you
know I think this is what happens when
societies
collapse and I don't think we can blame
people for doing this you disaster is a
hard hard thing to
face and look I see I see the madness if
you got a social media platform getting
a th comments every day you see the
madness in
society I don't blame people for falling
into
madness some of you will fall into
madness
too maybe you already have done into
selfishness into greed into
nihilism but I can't blame you it's very
human and Society will tell you you have
a choice in the face of
disaster to turn away to tell yourself a
story that it's not real that it's not
going to happen that it's only natural
the changing of the
seasons and if you do
that you can probably do what you wanted
to do all along you can be selfish you
can ignore it you can get that kitchen
renovation and you can tell yourself
that the poverty that is growing in
society that the that is infecting
everybody else may never darken your
door and you don't have to do what the
biblical Widow did you don't have to
give everything in the face of chaos you
have a choice to make right you have to
choose either yourself or
others you know I worked in Japan for a
couple of
years and at that time I lost my
mind I fell into a deep depression
depression and I spoke to my Japanese
Junior and I told him how watching these
millionaires obsess about money as the
world collapsed around them made me sick
and how I couldn't eat and how I
couldn't
sleep that kid his name was Kos and his
English wasn't good he said to me yes
yes I understand the problem is these
men have very small
Hearts you know sometimes I
wonder sometimes I wonder why it's me up
here from a broken home broken family
from
poverty struggling often with my mental
health sometimes struggling to get out
of bed every
day sometimes I wonder where all the
good kids are all the nice kids with the
nice
families that go home to lovely big
houses and have lovely meals and lovely
dining
tables where are they why is it
me what are
we what are we as
humans are we people who have to choose
between ourself and
others do our hearts have only room for
one of these
ideas or can we be something
more can we be
bigger can we be people who care not
only for ourselves our immediate
families us as
individuals but those around us society
as
well can we fit both of these things
into our
hearts can we take what we need but also
more than that after that find something
left to to give even if it's only two
copper
coins I believe that we can
no I don't believe that I believe that
we have
to if we don't the thing will
collapse but to finish I would like to
answer the question for me and you will
have your own
opinions what does it mean to be human
in a time of
disaster what does it mean to be human
in a collapsing
economy and me personally I agree with
C the job of a human in face of a
disaster is to try to prevent that
disaster that's what I'll be trying to
do and I hope you'll try to Good Luck
thank
you well Gary that was sensational